hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys will
heute sitzen wir oder ich sitzt auf dem
sofa murat hinter der kamera
heute gibt ein video über mich und sehr
wichtiges thema ja irgendwie ja
und zwar sollen sich was passiert und
deswegen ist uns sitzt die idee gekommen
oder eben der anlass dazu da dass jetzt
dieses video drehen
wenn euch unterwegs in karlsruhe und da
war es eine situation da waren zwei
jungs die haben irgendwie am brunnen
randaliert klingt jetzt bisher wir haben
mit as rom gespritzt
ja genau und dann ist eben die polizei
wieder früh gekommen und die haben dann
gesagt ja ich sonst bitte unterlassen
und ich glaube sogar sagt die sonne
platz verlassen gehört dem sogar gesagt
sie soll den platz verlassen und sich
einer der beiden jungs er hat sich da
hat aber auch immer so eine mütze an
wieder moral und darunter die mütze bis
hierhin gedrückt und beim vorbeigehen
oder beim weggehen hat er dann eben sagt
wenn der wüsste wie viele abonnenten ich
habe im radio nicht wer uns angeguckt
ok ja und zwar geht es um das thema
youtube und um milch als youtube also
ich bin jetzt seit vier jahren jetzt auf
youtube und macht mittlerweile also seit
zwei jahren machen wir im prinzip nur
youtube aber was heißt nur youtube wir
machen meine youtube-videos wir ich habe
meinen online shop und es ist halt immer
ein bisschen mehr als das was ihr da
draußen und ich möchte schaut einfach
ein bisschen was erzählen darüber wie
ich dazu gekommen bin und was ich gerade
mache und was sich in zukunft plane
also ich einiges verändert genaue zahl
genau
also ich habe wie gesagt vor vier jahren
damit angefangen damals habe ich ja noch
studiert und hab dann auch schon die
samira gehabt die war schon auf der welt
und hab da einfach nur so angefangen aus
hobby weil ich einfach meine rezepte mit
der ganzen welt teilen wollte und
hatte damals natürlich noch nicht der
abend wie schnell das jetzt alles wächst
und wie groß ist jetzt auch alles
geworden ist und das ist ja und
mittlerweile ist es echt so groß
geworden ich lade drei videos die woche
hoch mindestens manchmal sind sogar vier
manchmal auch fünf videos also es kommt
immer darauf an was von anlass gerade da
ist und ich gebe noch immer sehr viel
mühe mit meinen videos und natürlich bin
ich jetzt mittlerweile auch nicht mehr
alleine also ganz am anfang weiß
natürlich ganz alleine vor der kamera
man kann dem rad mit dazu
rausgeworfen ja dann hatte murat wieder
rausgeworfen als weltstadt kameramann
der welt mittlerweile haben wir wie so
ein kleines familienunternehmen
ich habe einfach zwei jungen skater
kamera die eben filmen
wir haben ihr shop unsere freunde und
jetzt ist wirklich für seine kleine
familie geworden ein kleines
familienunternehmen kann man sagen
samira macht ja auch ab und zu mit und
ja es macht doch wirklich alles super
viel spaß denn ich kann mich total frei
entfalten kann kreativ sein und im
prinzip kann ich gerade kochen und
backen worauf ich lust habe und
natürlich auch worauf meine zuschauer
lust haben was natürlich viele nicht
sehen dass es wirklich mit sehr viel
arbeit verbunden ist also im moment ist
es wirklich so wir arbeiten eigentlich
sechs sieben tage die woche in frage und
der tag beginnt morgens und endet dann
am abend und es geht natürlich nein das
ist tagen morgens beginnen endet also
nein der arbeit behalten
also wir gehen ja machen bis kurz bevor
wir ins bett gehen beantworten noch
fragen oder e mails und dass er das was
viele auch nicht sehen
klar geht es jetzt bei uns auch ganz gut
weil die kinder halt auch so gut
mitmachen die samira also wenn ich sie
fragt was machen wir heute was man heute
schatz war auf was so lustig es parat
beispiel kuchen backen
ja deswegen geht es ja auch alles ganz
gut aber muss ich natürlich auch dazu
sagen ich vermisse es auch so ein
bisschen was ich früher gemacht habe
und zwar habe ich ja eigentlich
grundschullehramt gelernt und war auch
als lehrerin tätig und da es einfach
zeitlich alles nicht mehr so vereinbar
war habe ich mich eben vor zwei jahren
dazu entschieden okay ich gehe jetzt
erstmal weg von der schule und mache
jetzt meine youtube videos dazu muss ich
sagen das finden wir vor zwei jahren
wirklich sehr
sehr schwer denn ich hab die klasse die
ich in der ersten klasse übernommen habe
in ende der zweiten abgegeben und ich
gerade dieses alter war eben schwierig
abzugeben weil wenn sie in der ersten
klasse sind da kommen sie alles
kindergartenkinder sie können nicht
lesen und nicht schreiben und rechnen
und das haben wir ihnen ja alles
beigebracht und dann habe ich so ende
der zweiten klasse abgegeben da haben
sie dann eben alles schon gekonnt und
ich habe sie wirklich gesehen wie sie
aufgewachsen sind und der abschied fiel
mir sehr schwer morath
damals habe ich gesagt ich mach nicht
mit der schule weiter weil genau an
dieser schule keine stelle frei war zu
dem zeitpunkt und ich wollte dann
eigentlich im dezember einsteigen wenn
meine kolleginnen in schwangerschafts
urlaub gegangen werden und dann ging
aber wie gesagt alles mit youtube so
schnell dass es irgendwie also es hat
sich einfach zeitlich nicht mehr ergeben
und ich hätte einfach zu wenig zeit auch
als für uns also für uns als familie
gehabt ja mittlerweile neulich war ich
wieder an der schule und haben da haben
wir noch viele möglichkeit genau danach
ach gott ganz vergessen und danach kam
ungefähr vier fünf sechs mal die
möglichkeit wieder einzusteigen an dem
eben die stelle an der schule angeboten
wurde
aber ich wollte es einfach nicht zu
sagen damit ich einfach so ein bisschen
noch ja das ausleben kann was wir jetzt
machen also youtube und ja mittlerweile
muss ich sagen ich mache wirklich super
gerne aber mir fehlt der teil in der
schule auch ein bisschen und wir waren
19 tierpark und da habe ich auch eine
schulklasse gesehen oder eine
kindergartenklasse wartet mit zwei
lehrerinnen und ich hab dann so
hingeguckt und war gerade mit den kids
spazieren und es hat mir dann schon also
ein bisschen angst hatte ich so ein
bisschen mich sagt man da vor sehnsucht
nach der schule ja und immer wenn ich
auch mit meinen kolleginnen mal zusammen
wenn dann dann fehlt mir das einfach und
ich habe mich jetzt dazu entschlossen
die musste was vor ca
ja genau ich war dann vor zwei wochen
nach an der schule und zwar ist das
abschiedsfest gewesen von
damaligen schülern die sind jetzt ende
vierter klasse und ich konnte nicht zum
abschiedsfest gehen weil wir zu der zeit
in amerika waren in den usa und ich habe
sie dann einfach vorher besucht und habe
dann eine schürze mitgebracht für jeden
und haben sich super gefreut was nur
ganz komisch war als ich vor zwei jahren
die schule verlassen hatte ging ich als
frau ist und diesmal kam ich als sally
also es war ein bisschen ja ich weiß
nicht wie ich glaube die wussten selber
nicht so ganz ob sally oder frauchen und
die wollten ein fotos und autogramme von
mir haben
naja also für mich was bisschen komisch
aber die haben sich total gefreut dass
ich da war und ich habe mich sehr
gefreut die klasse wieder zu sehen und
vor allem wollte ich auch unbedingt
nochmal sehen denn nach der vierten
trennen die sicher und gehen auf
weiterführende schulen und
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr die
möglichkeit gehabt alle kinder auf
einmal wiederzusehen
deswegen lag mir sehr am herzen und ja
da war ich ein bisschen hellhörig und da
ist schon wieder eine stelle frei an der
schule und ich habe mich jetzt echt dazu
entschlossen wieder ein paar stunden in
der schule zu arbeiten weil es fehlten
einfach also es fehlt mir und ich denke
das ist den kindern auch bestimmt viel
spaß macht und du findest du auch gut
für uns dass wir mit über gesprochen ob
es machen soll oder nicht findet und bei
allem erfolg von youtube hin oder her
und was gelernt genau ich habe lehrerin
gelernt
ich finde sowas in ehrenwerter beruf
lehrerin ganz aber wir können sie auch
schreinerin sein oder bäcker oder kunden
ein paar jahre herabsetzen oder am
kastels fensterbilder und auf jeden fall
ich finde es richtig cool und vor allem
das ist eigentlich kein rückschritt
vielleicht sagen jetzt manche leute
nicht mehr sehr gut aber ich würde sagen
bei 18.000 abonnenten - echte zu sagen
also ich hätte auch ja ich habe schon
gedacht dass das mit einem youtube kanal
wahrscheinlich gut wird weil ich es
einfach liebe was ich mache aber das ist
in so kurzer zeit so schnell wächst
hätte ich glaube ich selber auch nie
erwartet also ich würde echt überrollt
dann die who also die 100000 waren sie
die magische grenze
und da habe ich gedacht war
hunderttausend sechsstellig krass also
ich sag's erstmal fast 800.000
ja also es ist einfach so ich möchte mir
einfach wieder ein bisschen zeit für die
schule nehmen und natürlich mache ich
youtube weiter
ich kann mich jetzt aber noch nicht
sagen ob ich weiterhin drei videos die
woche hochladen werde ob so oder auch
mal weniger werden oder mehr keine
ahnung ich wollte eigentlich nur mit dem
video das am mittag dass ich das wieder
machen weil auch immer die frage kommt
wie machst du das schule und war mir
eigentlich das wichtigste nicht youtube
arena genau die will ich kein beruf ja
als ich lese immer öfter unter den
videos dass viele schreiben möchte ich
mich jetzt auch die oberin werden oder
auf der messe werde ich oft von eltern
dann auch angesprochen die dann sagen
meine tochter mein sohn die möchten sich
jetzt auch ein beispiel an die nehmen
wollen youtube in werden
und ich stehe immer da und denke mir
okay ich klar dass mal kurz also ich
mein youtube ist ja kein beruf den man
lernen kann und ich glaube man kann man
im rat nur die ausbildung zum weltbesten
kameramann da werden auch weil mir die
auswahl zwischen kameramann mit spaß
beiseite youtuber ist kein beruf den
kann man nicht lernen und ich finde
bevor man irgendwie so dem traum im kopf
hat youtube zu machen berühmt zu werden
muss man sich einfach bewusst machen
dass so was auch immer ganz schnell
vorbei sein kann also klar ist heute
backen und kochen trend und die youtube
videos sind trend und alle schauen rein
aber wer weiß was morgen oder nächstes
jahr passiert und was sollte halt immer
was festen der hinterhand haben und
einfach was richtiges lernen sag ich
jetzt mal als ohne jetzt es abzuwarten
was ich mache aber man sollte einmal was
richtiges lernen und dass ich einfach
die gefahr dass viele vor allem in
jungen jahren sich eben gerade die
großen youtuber dann als vorbild und als
beispiel nehmen und ja so das leben in
saus und braus und ich finde das sollte
man sich nicht weg mitnehmen
also ja dann kann er die boxen nebenher
machen so wie ich also ich habe auch
beides parallel gemacht und dann eben
irgendwann an einen punkt entschieden ok
zeitlich geht es nicht mehr mein start
auch noch 24 stunden und deswegen hatte
ich mich ja dann vor zwei jahren dafür
entschieden
aber wie gesagt so das herz sagt kommt
er wieder ein paar stellen die schule
wahrscheinlich hat mich jetzt viele für
verrückt aber ja murat meinte also ich
hab mir gesprochen und gesagt sally
also zu dem augenblick als ich da eben
mit der seele gesprochen habe als deine
augen vor gefunkelt haben wusste ich
dass du wieder in die schule will genau
und ehemaligen besetzt wie gesagt also
ihr könnt euch trotzdem mich als vorbild
nehmen ich arbeite noch keine falschen
vorbilder es gibt sachen wie heutzutage
supermodel fußballstar bereit für alles
ja alles brauchst du wirklich alles im
leben ist nicht immer alles können und
talent du brauchst auch immer sehr sehr
viel glück dass wir hatten wir bis jetzt
immer wir haben nicht die leute meine
eltern die uns immer die rolle habe
unterstützen die gehälter ganz ehrlich
hätte es youtube gar nicht funktioniert
meine eltern haben mir sogar ihren ihren
urlaub verschoben also die ganze familie
in der theorie wartet auf meine eltern
und die haben jetzt den urlaub
verschoben damit wir jetzt noch unsere
videos drehen können und erst in den
ferien und damit die dann mit samira was
unternehmen können und uns auch mal die
kids abnehmen können dass wir das buch
machen können was wir gerade machen und
dann hoffentlich komme vielleicht eine
woche mit meinen eltern zusammen
wir möchten da wirklich und auch wenn es
eine halbe zum und wir möchten lieber
ein bisschen zurückschrauben
ein bisschen weil die familie wichtiger
dass ihr beruf ist wie sie es gelernt
und er sagt nie zuvor schon gesagt hat
ich habe irgendwann angst dass ich
vielleicht so rauskommen könnte also
klar habe ich gelernt und habe das auch
in der praxis aber ich habe auch ein
bisschen angst natürlich dass ich weiß
dann kann man das verlernen
ich glaube ich glaube es hat man auch
drin aber ja ich möchte hat wieder gerne
in meinen alltag integrieren und ich
weiß noch nicht ob ich jetzt jeden tag
in der schule bin oder ein paar tage die
woche oder mal am stück als ich weiß
nicht wie es dann in der praxis wird
jedenfalls ab september es gibt einfach
trends die verschwinden er nichts für
die ewigkeit ich gebäude welches
beispiel studivz stellt mama in
sicherheit
gedacht ist das jetzt her dass das
youtube vids nicht mehr weiter wächst
wird immer größer ich denke auch mit
viel viel größer als es jetzt aber ist
wenn youtube ich wäre würde ich etwas
schönes im leben fehlen ehrlich sagen
aber ich denke unser dem wir trotzdem
schön oder youtube angefangen wenn wir
trotzdem die familie die wir setzen alle
gesund und am hungertuch nagen wie auch
nicht wenn beide arbeiten länger und man
arbeitet ja auch zum schuss und guckt
mich an als ich sagte ich mag nicht am
hungertuch
also ich hoffe ja nee also was ich oft
auch unter meinen videos oder auf
instagram vor allem lesecafé jungen
mädels diesen schreiben im sektor ist
mein größtes vorbild da finde ich auch
echt total geehrt aber ich finde man
sollte einfach unterscheiden ihr könnt
euch gerne mich als vorbild nehmen mich
als lehrerin mich als mama mich als
ehefrau als hausfrau aber ich denke
nicht mich als youtube drin vielleicht
weil ja wie gesagt ich liebe das was ich
mache und ich bin es auch gut was ich
mache wird auf keinen fall abwerten
aber ich denke man muss sich halt
einfach bewusst sein was du du bist und
sollte eben wirklich was richtig ist was
handfestes ihnen gerne am liebsten im
handwerk ist immer coulton handwerk ist
immer was er hoffe dass ich wollte
eigentlich spielen sich immer
architektin werden und habe der elften
klasse ein praktikum gemacht und wollte
es dann doch nicht mehr wobei der beruf
sehr schön ist aber ich habe gemerkt ich
kann doch nicht so kreativ sein wie
meine ich sein möchte wegen ganz und
bauvorschriften gemacht wie wir doch
nicht mit lehrerin
da kann man nämlich alles was man möchte
als kreativ sein
genau das wollte ich euch mitteilen und
bin ich mal gespannt auf eure reaktionen
und hoffe dass ich das jetzt auch
verstehe dich mein für euch wehren hat
sich wahrscheinlich nicht viel
wie gesagt vielleicht ein paar videos
weniger aber ich glaube in bakken kommt
sowieso keiner hinterher gras ja doch ja
so moment herzens meine
herzensangelegenheit
lange war es scheine von links kommt
nichts jetzt kommen die ganze
schwäbische sprüche schau mal schlechte
bauweise auf jeden fall macht es nimmt
euch bietet die richtigen vorbilder auch
eure eltern als vorbilder also nehmt
eure eltern als vorbilder die haben es
geschafft zu ernähren
die meisten von euch haben
wahrscheinlich keinen hunger gelitten
nehmt euch wirklich solche realen
vorbildern eben bei youtube habt thema
auch wenn ihr wenn ihr jetzt bei uns
immer reinschaut ist immer eine
momentaufnahme genau die leute fragen
sie mich mal so harmonisch alles so toll
ist das alles nur momentaufnahmen
es ist was ganz normales dass ich auch
mal streitet ja ich will euch gar nicht
sagen wie oft ich einfach das haus
verlasse
sauer auf mich zu
zu 90 prozent zu rechnen was meint ihr
was für diskussionen stehe wenn ich dass
ich meinen schwäbischer ehemann wenn ich
mal was für 93 hohe strafe 53 auf jeden
fall etwas ganz ganz normales ist auch
meine familie mal streitet das ist das
salz in der suppe kamera sagen also
wirklich gelingt es was ihr auf youtube
sieht auch nicht immer es war übrigens
sei wichtig dass geschwister sich
streiten
genau so wächst die beziehung ehrlich
ich hab nur streiten neun geschwistern
auf jeden fall nimmt nicht nur zu herzen
ich mache auch mal ein witz da ist
vielleicht manchem ich witzig manche
lachen sich erde stimmt das also ich
kenne ihn ja ich weiß wer gemeint aber
er meint nie was böse ist vielleicht mal
sozusagen um mal einfach mal klären
aber dein humor verstand er saniert es
ist sowieso keine freunde ich muss jetzt
weiter backen ok alles da alles bescheid
gelernt was spaß macht der ausbildung
oder ein studium oder ein studio oder
irgendwann irgendwas aber macht etwas ja
also das wollte ich nur kurz mitteilen
und ja gut es gibt ja regelmäßig meine
videos mittwoch freitag sonntag und ab
und zu zwischen ja also viel spaß bei
den mit den anderen videos wie mache ich
mein schluss über das jetzt komisch
kein baby update keinen sagt ja also bis
zum nächsten mal bis zu sechsmal sagte
einiger service erdnuss er sagt es im
auf youtube nein keine ahnung
auf wiedersehen ich wünsche euch den
wunderschönen tag rechtlich ist nicht
kennen tschüss
michael jetzt anfange ich würde sagen
hallo hallo du kannst ja auch die durch
einen feuerreifen springen
tipp das ganze tut